olá votaram antes mas é um prazer estar
aqui é ea apresentação está acusava no
meio e tenho 34 anos sou psicóloga
construções sou teimosa gosta de levar a
moça mas mais importante tudo sou
curiosa e sou inquieta e esse é
fundamentalmente um membro da oposição
na vida
se eu tivesse que escolher uma exposição
era provavelmente esta exposição resume
a minha forma de ser e de estar na vida
e acho que através da instituição que eu
vou guiar eu estava com os passar como
massagens mensagem para hoje quando tive
que arranjar uma forma profissional de
juntar as minhas duas paixões são a
psicologia positiva porque entre a
ciência e as viagens futuras viagens
ventos não as de fora tal como tantos
fora e encontrar um novo esta forma de
trabalhar e nunca encontrei foi é se
entende em inglês foi criado nos estados
unidos mas significa pensar grande é uma
expressão que visitou 13 anos e uso para
falar de perspectiva quanto ao pensar
grande tem muito mais a ver com
perspectiva do que pensar em grande e
tem a ver com a cessão de ver todo mundo
ao mesmo tempo núcleo cada coisa
esta é minha forma de trabalhar e fazer
isso eu faço durante dias e ou escrevo
palco com pessoas com as pessoas a
evitarem que nenhum cliente só com eles
há informações de informações com física
e me vida é inventada que vivia e todos
os dias é um desafio é não é sempre
fácil fazer forma que eu fui escolhido
para marcar o meu produto curso carne
imprópria em santo cristo e não é só
bonito é muito complicado às vezes traz
muitos desafios e implica também em
andar muitas vezes com a casa às costas
então essas coisas são feitas em vários
seriados sítio ano curto um desenho em
casa há uns tempos pode ser em barcelona
onde eu vivi uns anos e não tenho estudo
da casa
a cinelândia pode ser mais conhecidos e
os meses no brasil nos estados unidos
onde passei semanas mas quando é o
mercado interno
moll as duas coisas têm que estar sempre
uma é um bom copo e um café mas ao fim
só depois abrir o computador e trabalhar
falar com as pessoas eo nível de
baunilha para ascender à noite em que o
guarda está cá dentro
e com esse o vira nem sempre é fácil
juntar tudo
a única coisa que eu sai é o caminho e
onde eu estou e encaminhei a andar assim
viver desta forma então isto é muito
raso os conceitos de estudos latino com
o que chama de psicologia positiva
é o que eu faço quando o ciclo de
efetiva e as viagens de dentro tudo
juntas islâmicos com o site os primeiros
contatos inclusive através das histórias
que eu vou colhendo o minuto a minuto em
minha vida pessoal depois no trânsito as
histórias que o corpo para ilustrar este
exemplo recente cirurgia e se eu passar
porque é psicologia positiva que estava
perguntasse ao que têm veículos dfrv tem
a ver com sorrisos com andar centro
super contente muito feliz e muito bem
disposto e psicologia positiva assim ou
aterros para que o fizeram ser
engenheiro instante se dirigem às vezes
acontece
as suspeitas inclusive é muito simples
tem mesmo como a ciência é igual a
psicologia a única coisa que se foca no
paço com que sua vez pelas florestas e
você tem a ver com chegar ao melhor nós
próprios não têm dizer quando áfrica em
conteúdo nem rir o tempo histórico já
vinha bem nos rio tem pintado e teve com
isso sem usar monetária não ter um grego
florista consolava e tem a ver com esse
conhecimento humano e no fundo chegarmos
a ser tudo que podemos ser um bom e com
mau então porque como é que eu descobrir
como é que eu entrei no mundo disse que
o dia de quinta
este é o primeiro livro que hoje a sair
eu já vivia nesta forma já sentia que
havia 15 aqui mas nunca tinha visto uma
teoria não tenho nada que dissesse até
então
e quando eu caí este livro que o fluido
de reais sem palavras dentro seria a
palavra intenção consciência palavra do
flor do fluxo e que começava a se marcar
dentro da área
a descrição do livro mais honesta um
livro que apresenta exemplos de como se
pode desfrutar mais da vida
uma viagem viagens aéreas ou através do
do rendimento enviada pelo caminho com
deficiência e osso bastante científica e
rigorosa e não gosto nada dessas coisas
do software gratuito a hungria que tuita
pensava eu é parte de ter alguma coisa
que é uma ciência que explicavam que a
gente tem muita curiosidade ele traz
mais e mais um então livro encontrei o
time havia é o fluxo está o fluxo é
quando as atividades são realizadas pela
experiência em si vale por si próprias
expectativas futuras fazendo com que a
vida justify no presente em investigar
os banhos e que tudo pareça é o fruto do
presente eo presente dos frutos pequenas
coisas grandes coisas pelas coisas em si
espero que elas vão trazer pois te ver o
que vai acontecer no palacinho eo livro
continuava livre continuava se assim não
acontecer o trabalho é um estado cada um
temporário da trabalho enquanto uma
experiência entre o conselho determinar
a qualidade das nossas vidas que é o
máximo que nós pudemos aproximar-se
frente mais uma vez e fui dar trabalho
não é que não tenha a ver com um andar
contente nem com o sorriso teve com
andar atrás de alguma coisa tenha assim
que ficar dentro e esse incentivo era
que o que me fazia sentir esta procura é
este curso é clean e ir atrás do faz
sentido em todo momento mas tem grandes
teorias é uma forma por isso é que eu
comecei por viver a forma como vive é
uma forma de desfrutar de uma forma
muito consciente ea via sem vender a
idéia de que se estamos mais felizes
honestamente sálvia de hoje me
perguntarem se eu sofri isso eu não faço
a minima ideia quem responder
normalmente não mais do que toda a gente
que está aí o que eu sei é se esta
procura dos sentidos cada coisa é
entender por que ele fale da vida nos dá
sempre para continuar a viagem
então como eu tenho isso muito claro que
não gostei tanto do clube no livro o meu
próximo passo só podia ser com ir até os
estados unidos e com certeza de reais e
perguntar lhe se queria trabalhar com
ele e eu disse que não que tiveram que
escolher ou não mas talvez fosse bom e
evitar a prática
então foi o que eu fiz deve ter uma
prática e 11
antes que você está cada vez mais sobre
o que a psicologia positiva pois é no
final esses conceitos aqui uma resumida
que alguém da comunidade é muito mais
havia muito mais tema e conseguimos
ficar a perceber o que queria dizer e
como é que isto é brincar nas coisas
entretanto com todo esse conhecimento
fiz o que tive no início e as empresas
das escolas outras instituições tentar
pôr em prática os conceitos que o final
e nos links extratos com linha prata e
com a forma como eu e vivendo vida e
isto é o que eu faço os meus dias de uma
forma profissional
então o que ele quer propor é
basicamente uma viagem porque numa
viagem pelo mundo do vento da cirurgia
positiva eu fui descobrindo nos meus
dias
então eu vou tentar demonstrar a teoria
vou estar me que tinha no fundo está
presente na vida de toda a gente saiba
viagens aqui então o primeiro ponto pra
mim enquanto mesmo lugar a terra que a
gratidão a gratidão teve com
conhecimentos e aprender a precisão
profundos vindo de dentro é uma
tranquila o conhecimento de deus ou
amigo que deus tem a ver com o número do
subúrbio sul ou com o mal que isto está
a acontecer então a última das coisas
práticas que os materiais ela já está
grato por bens materiais eventualmente
acontecem o tempo que estou no país
diferente em r 1.650 é uma coisa com a
qual eu estou realmente trata da um
jeitaço é uma coisa que eu posso fazer
e a gente tem e estou grato por
recuperar coisas que tinha perdido esse
foi um caso e trabalha com um computador
pequeno e alto em 22 meses pelo
computador supercontente comprado em
segunda mão num grande negócio porque o
computador no aeroporto tom jobim chega
o esboço para cá para as chaves e menos
por enquanto não há informação lá dentro
e às vezes meio da noite ligando o
aeroporto de munique a visita de amorim
que temos aqui seu computador no
aeroporto de bonito e não acreditava que
tiveram que mandar a fotografia do
cinema polícia ontem que uma vaca tem
medo que eu conheço um único em atraso
já que não pode usar o futuro viável
as coisas acontecem e europa é que não
só fiquei política e fez o mesmo e me
grato pelo espírito de ensino
depois enquanto entidade crime eo há uns
anos atrás e os estados unidos a
conduzir e eu tinha pânico convite ele
mesmo cria quase a tapa
é o fim de que deveria eu tenho que não
sou nada dessas coisas agradecer ao
cosmo
o após ouvir eu sentia realmente você
sabe precisamos da concessão junto foi
mais um dia
correu tudo bem não acontecer nada mal
este instituição só por aqui dizia fez
com que fosse capaz de desfrutar mais e
mais casas atingir 95 - da estrada em
serviços e mesmo por exemplo aquela
viagem
mas não foram só as paisagens bonitas o
o opaco viagem eo rebanho foi importante
essa viagem sozinho nem tantas outras
eram as suas deficiências
eram as conversas e 80 eram os encontros
que produziam de corpo inteiro pra
coorpin tais conversas que o presente
certame perspectiva das coisas como é
que se viu coisas diferentes como é que
é possível fazer coisas de frente que
não precisaria do outro lado que nunca
tive e outras histórias é que estava a
acontecer há exatos exatamente aqui o
mesmo tempo então isso é o companheiro
são histórias que permite à união o
órgão o espectro de cinza ênfase à
capital que realmente ainda que não seja
a minha vida há sempre dúvidas problemas
acontecerem uma coisa e essa é uma
história que pode ter fundamento estrada
eu acho que o fato de estar grata por
isso coisa completamente óbvio
acho que só é possível por possuir um
perfil de falar hoje conquistar dinheiro
com isso com mais calma e atenção plena
superlotado no aqui e agora não eu chamo
me sentir mais em si tanto quanto está
actualmente são guiados por esse mundão
afora não há dentro a tu é que o momento
em que ela circunstância 55 passar assim
sem correr e pensar nas coisas do que
contente por ver o cruzeiro é quando os
milagres porque milagres da vida
acontecem e oprime o canicense ataques
há pouco tempo ela vai em é o impacto
que isso pode ser o caminho de santiago
é que eu não sei se alguém já fez querer
influenciar é que eu é que o momento em
tudo que é pra fazer aquela linha não
mais na loja coisa que pode fazer é
certo daqui é o caminho e isso às vezes
até mesmo perder dinheiro a mais difícil
não estamos mais como santo com a
questão foi na linha que vai ter que
estar em qualquer outro lugar
na primeira noite é impessoal primeira o
velho estava colado em 6 de dezembro
sozinha a caminhada caminhada um tiro
nas costas e teve entre maio e setembro
cresceu ainda mais e chega primeiro ao
ver que não havia lugar para ficar no
espaço e ficar comigo e circunstâncias
do crime como minha mochila muito
pensava a meio por dina mas já está
curado e vai pra onde o pv vamos tentar
que vou ver o que acontece
eu acho que se a gente pratica a gente
tiver por exemplo as coisas e
eventualmente anos resolver alguma forma
tentem e acho que quem literalmente
assim a ver o que acontecia
não estava lá estava presente estava
inteira está tudo ganho de bamba venda
rendia bbb de carlos freitas africanas
fmi down e sentar-se à mesa com a maior
das naturalidades com se tivesse que
inventar perdeu 150 então eu tenho é que
produzir esta noite mas que eu estava
super dos pra tentar mesmo frio e até
sua aventura menina no chão para fazer o
caminho de santiago em pleno inverno não
é uma aventura bonita pode fazer uma
certa altura estava a trocar mensagens
pop como nike teve vida que eu sinto que
ela ia arranjar um jumento
pelo que vi a minha vida ser resolvida
por sua clientela muito tempo que era
por menos provável para escapar daquela
situação possível num espanhol que
afirmou já sabe coisas boas acontecem é
quem tem o coração bom
lembra que hoje o desenho casa publicar
nesta noite fica esse review nesta casa
lusinha que é possível desenhar essas
início a uma massa cozida que elas fazem
também sem que haja negócio é mesmo essa
altura e no dia 30 tinha duas marcas das
mãos
corre no milagre da multiplicação da
massa emergência para que ele escolhesse
o massa e resolvi dar uma volta concluiu
suas criancinhas sem fome vamos ter
dinheiro para comer
eu resolvi levar o crédito mais fácil eu
não vim aqui pra noite larsen mas
significa que existe um pouco a
conquistar o cinturão esse vício já que
informa entre os 30 mais rápida que iria
jantar que ele saia no trabalho o
crescimento do contrato vai ver isso é
passado
claro que isso deu três anos a conversa
não é só prestar os melhores a bola que
o milan então parte da filha não tem
muito valor e até acho que não quero que
a bateria pode faz nas segundas linhas
que estão aí mas amanhã eu voltar vou
brincar mesmo e não teme ser viável
vou continuar a minha intenção é
entregar nossa e sair comemorando o
final moça foi boa troca de passes entre
as cinco coisas que eu acho que acontece
quando se está presente quando está lá
que ele está cansado e quando está com
vontade de viver seja o que for que
aconteça nem cheguem às origens do cob
está sentado aqui e acho que isso também
dá o outro o outro você consegue ter
vulnerabilidade eu estar lá vai levar um
tempo você é só subir expressivamente em
outra frase entregar se de corpo e alma
então quando está chovendo enquanto
entregas porque a alma que realmente só
coisa alguma coisa para o sus e roma
o eqüino falei que nós somos jogar sem
bons e mal aconteceu já está na unidade
foi muito por esta prova olhar o menu
que se me parece que essa ritmo
alucinante de muitas formações em que o
segurado empresa positiva entre eles
estão duas equipas de uma forma mais
otimista ele só que ele também vai
trabalhar com costura no tempo passava o
meu gosto muito o valor confirma o valor
se e como gosta de viajar ficar sua
equipe mesmo trabalhar no restaurante
week onde não seria língua eu fazia meio
a eles que me deixava com pilha de
pratos amigo que estava com uma faca
então esse foi basicamente a posição
número lhe dado algumas chances
a novidade mais fortes assim que citando
que não vai treinar aqui e não seja na
escola eu vou mudar
a única coisa que eu sei que vai me
fazer pensar e cozinhar
esses anos o juro real é uma outra coisa
que expressa que sub-16 e também que
houve qualquer coisa
isso expressa tem a ver com esses três
cursos têm a ver com tiro no g4
construir os caminhos para dar pancadas
mais fracas em 1940 e teremos que você
minha confiança pra ficar à espera dos
seus claro que eu acho que essa é a
convidada é franca
é que os move construídos práticas que
não são imediatamente no caminho então
que ajuda o dia e esse é muitas vezes me
pergunta que eu viajo bastante com a
equipe viaja sozinho e as muitas vezes
tem coisas muito solicitadas nem
filiadas
então por lima já estavam conseguir
muita coisa pode acontecer
boa mar muitas vezes acontecem pelas
ordinárias 200 vezes acontece que o
motor gente basta ir brasil aquela que é
o porto com que a estrutura ia e
expressa é que o quim quase utilizar que
aconteça o que acontecer afirma bernard
réver você é muito engraçado porque é
uma coisa completa o rio ainda né
nós não pensamos em frente à escola
quando você olha a nossa maior angústia
que acontece confiante que ama a várias
histórias que acontecem entre gente
usava dinheiro - ferozmente por vai
virar série mais ou menos e vamos tentar
reviver engraçada e se trancou no
aeroporto de são paulo
perguntaram se eram de ketziot estava
ficando mais próximo do verificado em
janeiro
conviver no bolso não nos meus olhos
quarenta reais para chegar à casa de
câmbio não vai sumir e está pronto para
lutar com eles muito impressionado vai
conseguir se inscrever nesse ano
existem 50 reais processo é uma situação
que chegou aos estados unidos em um
super corrida com anilha pequenas e
ainda que tão grande no final
no passeio me ver como é que isto é mau
era quase do tamanho
entro no no autocarro e era preciso
moedas focada para apoiar o ataque não
tinha muita raiva
muitos dólares em notas e moedas é esse
fato é que essa turma pequena coleta em
uma troca por um seguro de que é grande
e ficar agachado moeda só podia ficar
vinheta rapariga pela marinha maior que
eu fiz essa tatuagem de um semanário tem
nada de uma senhora que me contaram que
ele estava meio frisa e talvez mesmo
orientava porque comdec e está apurando
peguei dinheiro seja feita nenhuma
conseguiu se adaptar o carro está a
cozinhar espacinho o zfs tanto que é
francês a encostar os pés e vários
salvar alguma forma a gente conseguir
aguentar os pequenos disse que o clube
segue o caminho é esse episódio também
trazem outra situação que se repetiu que
o amor ao outro ao amor ao próximo é uma
principal é um absurdo alguém pra não te
juro por cinco está lá estar lá
o amor pode servir como elemento
surpresa positiva não só com o meu amor
eu conseguia por exemplo que o sucesso
do filme que é o meu papel é gostosona e
já não vi que era um senhor que quando
precisava do menino e estava numa cidade
estranha às vezes entrava na loja de o
perder
assim o tráfego nas vias estarão em 2010
a conversa com elas aplicável a publicar
o que queremos um no outro
era o que se tem sido sempre calma saiu
no carro mais cheia pois há uma procura
que elas já foram iniciadas e hoje fui
lá e manda ir lendo algum tempo passava
os dias base em sozinho e trabalhava no
ibope mas havia aquela falta de civismo
e contará com 200 a 300 partilhares
muito que contar tudo enquanto que joão
moutinho pode movimentar o hawk-eye
pobre que toques a calvície pela fruta
que tanto irrita muito tempo aí vou
fazer qualquer coisa à minha procura
fazer uma coisa qualquer conquista
conhecer ele não que aquilo é um grupo
de qualidade que você quiser fora do seu
nome
os professores que têm algum tipo de
problema mental
efe sonho sociedades saibam não era pra
mim altura e
seu vice é uma coisa boa que a primeira
reunião ele disse que queria fazer que
só vinha o dinheiro que nos garante nada
mas a forma como ela se tornou
guerrilheiro como fizeram sempre parte
do grupo como tomaram e partilhar os
grandes dos planos de ouvir quem deixar
o ninho partilhar também fizeram com 60
estónia no lugar número limitado de um
ano e essa situação é que ele venceu
larga nestas duas crias do amor e
produto e os olhos nem a constituição do
caminho com cinco válvulas minha
história e e união e os outros que faz
com o site terá um significado ao
significado da anvisa ou a propósito de
vida são os outros é que não sei as
construtoras é que outros 20 esteve com
essas cidades têm seus grupos sociais
que encontrar as incríveis nas posições
conjuntas e pra mim isso é o cúmulo da
quarta edição está sabe que o caminho
dos procurados em kit que escutava vida
fm solitário né não os índios
isso é uma coisa que tenho as vias em
que cada vez mais alunos esquerdo que
neste caminho às vezes pelas suas
travessuras
dói muito perto os segmentos vezes e
assim celso nível é brutal
neste momento o que tenho de me senti é
que quando estou no pior é ter como é
sempre criar um bicho eu sic
desde que eu saí porque não sou capaz ao
inglês chamada alguma mensagem animal a
um abraço a uma capa que seja o que eu
mostro aqui é só estará em jogo estão lá
isso continua a fazer treino de paulo
é só você é que é especial porque é o
fábio tem nas suas peregrinações mais
força e mais difícil não é só eu que eu
e os outros próximo é que eu e os outros
próximo ea sociedade entre nossos
governos e esse é só sair muito clara é
que sempre dá vida a sua mãe vai mais
longe que nós queremos criar mais
simples vira tem inspirações
por exemplo enquanto na irlanda a
velocidade de maurin para ficar com a
filha lourdes é ficar afiado e vamos
punir o atleta não era tudo começando
muito positiva da cidade também
conhecido tempo a viver alguns erros e
teve que de sua extraordinária bonitas
qantas típicas das varinhas sus
trabalhava na padaria não teria nem
sempre os mais normais o que vier a
diferença
essas pessoas mostrar ao mundo
profissional reister manda a cef como
cidade maravilhosa cheia de super bonita
e se fizemos no seu projecto étnico
consigo e com o nosso mostrar que as
pessoas todas fazendo sociedade muito
mais vídeos e objetos e no filme de
tintim foi inspirado no filme em 2001
basicamente o que conta é a capacidade
de nosso estado das pequenas falhas de
engenharia e explicaram que visavam a
atenção aos filhos essas pequenas
histórias que fazer ao longo do tempo
crianças inscritas que funciona ao longo
do clínico acrescentando que no ano 2000
elas ficam os trouxeram um papelinho
física minha opinião é este encargo as
antas enfrentar ficavam me criar
transmissão do vírus explica
ele está sentindo
sim então é é pra mim essa posição com
michael ballack e há dois ou três dias
em uma cela da função era um usuário e
obrigado é perguntava o deslizamento
teria sempre evitou o gol
por isso acho que pra mim tenho a gente
o código esteja a 10 mil pés por uma
amiga minha e vou por aí que tem
aventuras e com as coisas de que na
procura e tem um kia possui viagem
facilita as coisas
mas alguns dias ele ganhou o níquel que
está disse na nota que a conhecia
é um absurdo que a província vai ter uma
conversa sobre o que querem
afinal nesse particular o céu é o que
estará a procura é o filho porque quebra
da procura quando começou a falar sobre
o que era previam aquela situação nova
quebra o santos assume pessoas podem
acontecer
isso tudo precisa ser lida na íntegra de
lado
a única coisa que posso garantir é que
vai ficar fazendo sua vida uma coisa
consigo explicar como é que o que é
viver a vida que nada é viver com esse
projeto tem muito clara costa que em
outros e os aplique uma resposta está no
caminho ele teria que ter muita coisa só
garante que está no filme thelma coisa
também é feito pelo entendimento e
franquias que ainda no primeiro tempo e
só serve de atalho nos purificar o
mercado deve resultar em nada vai mas no
final eu acho que a mensagem é a
mensagem que dizia um nível que não é
nada das suas áreas que têm muitos
céticos professores que dizia assim a
psicóloga mensagem é mais ou menos essa
não é espanhol e que não sei falar assim
da pergunta que a vida não faz sentido
esperar essa vantagem hoje e não se
esqueçam do que da análise que as voltas
santos o caminho
muito obrigado